tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono fuori j
oggi siamo su hyde hamsik che in
italiano significa nascondino
anche se non credo sia un nascondino
normale perché dal menu così non sembra
comunque click to enter entriamo in
questo mondo fantasma si parte così
buongiorno ci sono per caso tutti i 50
centesimi no perché sono miei dei loro
l'hanno guadagnato non sono miei 50
cittadini maledizione smette a
ricercarli gli ho detto di fermarsi e
anch'io sto dicendo ora è troppo tardi
no il cazzo tuberi dai si ritrovi cioè
l'ultima persona che deve uccidere o
cazzo
oddio pieni di 50 centesimi va bene così
premi shift percorrere usd per muoverti
ora dovresti scappare dalla porta o
chase capiamo bene mi è piaciuta che si
idea gran consiglio non è che si apre
una porta se prova ad aprire maledizione
non ci tengono aprirla va bene così
davanti agli amati corri corri corri
corri corri aprite che cosa faccio
qualcosa qui cos'è questo buongiorno
salve aprì la porta ai degli occhi
bellissimi e stato amore a prima vista
credo di essermi innamorato vabbè
parliamo senti zio non so che cosa vuoi
propri dietro c'è qualcosa c'è qualcosa
che mi stava inseguendo che si è fermata
a un millimetro ora noi e ci possiamo
ritenere fortunati sono proprio contento
di essere in questa stanza con te al
chiuso
[Musica]
parla fa qualcosa cosa facciamo non
lasciare che ti veda mi ha già visto ma
non fa niente nasconditi se se lo senti
arrivare chiudi gli occhi se perdi la
tua sanità mentale perfetto ragazzi
stiamo colleziona gli oggetti delle
memorie nascoste quali memorie nascoste
scusami eh riportali da me ti porterò
ciò che è richiesto sommo padrone
andiamo non sa precisamente dove stiamo
andando però qualsiasi imposta è meglio
di quello quindi va bene
hughes ma si possa capire cos'è forse
non chiudere il doppio si possono
chiudere gli occhi tipo in sc fila prima
la porta ragazzi perché se siamo qui è
un casino la permesso sonno fa vj ma che
ve le stanze pulite ragazzi ma è un
piacere entrare in queste stanze
veramente c'è un osso qui ragazzi un
rosso di un mammut non si sa come mai
va beh noi prendiamolo per sicurezza
abbiamo che cazzo sta succedendo
[Musica]
e stato un piacere che cazzo era quella
roba ragazze ok ok si avvicina con aprì
la porta a prima porta che se raga
ci sono delle sedie sul muro buongiorno
buongiorno mi sei bellissimo sei troppo
sexy
siamo morti non so perché siamo morti
non so che cazzo è successo non capisco
perché sto giocando a questo gioco
quindi è giusto posto cioè dove siamo
una stanza chiusa chiusa la prima volta
porta non si sa dove si ok che è
successo
centrati da qualche parte ma cos'è ha di
nuovo qui siamo di nuovo tool c'è un
tizio che mi segue non so se tu amico
non mi piace però andiamo avanti lo
stesso raga non so che cosa sta
succedendo non importa cosa fare se
siamo di nuovo qualora godevo
prenderesti oggetti qui che però non ho
capito che cosa servono e più che altro
non ho capito me sfuggire a quel tizio
io vado avanti ugualmente cos'è questo è
un poster di qualcosa non so che cazzo è
comunque è uno di quegli oggetti di
sicuro e ho paura di prenderlo perché
quella fare miss punta di sicuro quindi
laga non lo prendo a prescindere ma
cos'è questo è un altro oggetto a
picture
no no no fermo dove sei dove sei dove
sei
bastardo 26 dic in un cassetto ho
trovato una foto di qualcosa non so che
cosa era non si è manifestato a nessuno
per fortuna o per ragazzi allora forse
prima abbiamo avuto solo sfortuna ma
vara che controlliamo st porta se non
c'è nulla di strano
[ __ ] porca [ __ ] che cazzo ci
fai qui cosa chi ti dà il permesso di
stare dietro le porte far prender gli
spaventi pezzo di merda gli who died ara
[ __ ] io quelle porte lino alle tocco
più mi sa cos'è questo che bello che
bello prendersi daddy bear the dolls
i've ever
non ho letto perfetto n'importa non me
ne frega niente perché ce l'ha il sangue
sulla lampada ce ne va bene io non ho
capito come si fa a salvarsi da quel
tizio non l'ho capito perché ci sono
delle sedie sul soffitto ragazzi perché
a chi è che ci ha dato dentro con la pac
man è che posso sedermi anch'io mi curo
il culo al soffitto vediamo se mi trovo
io vado avanti anche se non sono vecchi
non sono
non so dove non solo vecchi degli occhi
gli occhi tranquilli gli occhi lavati i
denti per l'amor di dio ragazzi non si
può fare sto gioco non si capisce perché
ogni 4 secondi muoio si provo perché
altrimenti non ha idea di come fare ci
provo prendiamo l'osso perfetto adesso
punta del pezzente vai così voi così
corri con i cori carico ricaricarica
ritieni prenditi sta roba
sì e no che perfetto ho fatto loro
genova d'aiuto
sei troppo figo di murray ora guardarti
è veramente sei troppo bello se non
avessi notato che c'è un tizio che sto
arrivando nel corridoio che cazzo ti
guardi guardi aiuto
aiutami che cosa cazzo ti guardi dammi
la mano si può fare
io ci rinuncio non so come si gioca
questa roba non so perché mi abbiate
consigliato questa roba e non so perché
continuo a giocare ai videogiochi che mi
consigliate
cos'è sono inciampato mi hai fatto uno
sgambetto maledetto avo che stanno
dietro azioni ragazzi mi ricordano che
devo tenere la stanza più in ordine
comunque c'è una palla una palla se vai
così ho trovato una palla ho raggiunto
lo scopo della mia vita
giocavo che la palla
chiudi gli occhi se ricorda fa vj
significa che non ci sei
funziona la cantilena le secolo bene non
so che cosa era quella roba era
veramente brutta comunque non importa e
non è che può aprire le porte vero no
non può aprire le porte perché io sono
tanto tanto buono cos'è questa una foto
o disegnati miei sogni veri riguardanti
il mio futuro
madonna che futuro fantastico comunque
voglio dirtelo da d'amico amico continua
a cercare ci ho parlato buon non so se
mi stanno prendendo in giro perché
ancora non c'è nessuno comunque qua c'è
un quadro bellissimo tra l'altro è c'è
qualcosa che presentano come al solito
non avevo nel cassetto inutile
non ci sei o non ci sei non ci sei non
ci sei non ci sei non ci sei non ci sei
non ci sei non ci sei ragazzi sono
troppo bravo cazzo forse non così bravo
ok ok ok calmi carissimi calmissimi
nell'altra stanza nell'altra [ __ ]
stanza ok facciamo il giro allora sto
durando di più delle vite precedenti non
so come mai ma meglio così allora
aspettate un attimo che fosse così
spunta di in fondo perfetto io non
vorrei trovarmi lo qui a prima porta
propria porta e propria porta che brutto
che dove dove sta andando perfetto stato
le migliori cazzo sta facendo si guardi
in ge un corridoio che cazzo fai così a
sta tornando nella stanza a quindi e là
in fondo è bene non so dove prendo sta
roba
adesso ci deve essere il tizio che
spunta perfetto allora chiudi gli occhi
maledetto non ci sei più
non ci sei più no continua a esserci ok
jari non fatta dopo un ora ce l'abbiamo
fatta il tizio ancora lì fondono sarà
nei corridoi a sinistra qua ho
dimenticato qualcosa l'orsacchiotto
l'orsacchiotto orsacchiotto perfetto dai
che ce la possiamo fare siamo a un rack
quando siamo a 4 quanti ce ne sono nove
sentiti oggi ho trovato tre o quattro
cose non so se ti servono prendi le
cinque altre cinque ragazze possibile
sto gioco come faccio ci sono poche le
stanze dove è finito ragazzi dove c'è ma
c'è il tomtom si è perso non ho capito
perché si è domandato lui si sa bomba
dai ragazzi è sparito non si sa perché
non è calato in sostanza e qui non c'era
gae abbiamo sì e smart adesso attacchi
manifesti si è smarrito pupazzo brutto
ok era lì è perfetto
torniamo indietro per oggi adesso che
sappiamo dove devo riuscire ad aprire
tutte le porte
forse ce la faccio forse se dio vuole ce
la posso fare che sia questo fa ricordi
gordic ho ricordi se se qua ho preso la
palla l'ho presa e l'ho presa non l'ho
presa e l'ho presa l'ha portata a
tradizione rischio un casino va beh
chimica non appare nel frattempo che c'è
sta roba che emerge dal terreno dai
chiudi gli occhi ragazzo poi c'è poi
faccia poi chiudere
pare sì sì faccio ragazzi ho l'ansia
miller e giura si può mai essere così
ansiosi per un video game show è
possibile cio l'ansia che ciò il cuore
che mi batte a mille vi giuro
vabbè dove devo prendere a foto mizio
devo prendere a foto prendi st [ __ ]
foto
prendi la non chiudere gli occhi ok io
non lo sento di giusto morendo
ho preso tutti gli oggetti a sinistra
mancano quelli a destra la che mancano
quelli a destra dove dove sa intanto non
lo stoppa bene prendiamo questo ragas
dovrei aver finito
dovrei aver finito devo tornare solo
indietro devo solo torna righe
solo tornare indietro ragazzi sotto di
dietro un so dov'è
non so dov'è non so dove corri corri e
basta cori e vasta cori e pazza sì ce la
posso fare
ma anche l'ultima stanza tutti
abbastanza si dove e li tieni tieni
tutto ma una memoria su una sola dove
dove dove ho dimenticato ditemi dove era
che non lo so ne manca uno come ho fatto
a dimenticarne una dove era dove sono
dimenticata dove io non so dove l'ultimo
oggetto non ne ho idea
al corsista stanza qui no non sia questa
stanza ma l'iniziale vabbè non fa niente
in fondo perfetto
style.it o cosa mi manca cosa ed io ho
trovato ho trovato trovato altro lato
ho trovato di mick ancora lì mica
domandato adesso come cazzo andato ad
esso draga non so dove devo rifarmi
tutte le stanze di nuovo sperando che
non no no no ci credo
ficcatelo nel didietro maledizione
regalo finito non si posso credere è che
questo serva di lezione a tutti perché
questo videogame ha una morale se non vi
lavate i denti finite così quindi la
watts evidenti dopo mangiato ragazzi che
sono qui l'episodio se vi do è piaciuto
come solo il tuo ha scelto un commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come in ogni video trovate la
descrizione senso dai prestiti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bene ragazzi
[Musica]